let's talk about Webster for a minute
one of the most important decisions
you're gonna make in that
transformational journey is selecting an
application platform as you know
WebSphere is the world's leading
application platform used by thousands
and thousands of enterprises running
over a million applications in
production today wherever you are on
that cloud journey WebSphere can meet
you there and take you to the next level
and what you see on the screen right now
is really a timeline of innovations from
the WebSphere portfolio so when you
think about that 1.0 stage of cloud
where customers are really focused on
price performance and efficiency
WebSphere is their websphere version 9
delivers a 15 times performance
improvement over version 6 where we were
just a few years ago so there's a lot of
value in moving up to the latest
releases in addition independent studies
from industry analysts suggest WebSphere
will give you a 25 to 100 percent
performance improvement over other
vendors and open source alternatives we
have one banking client in North America
that's processing 35 billion 35 billion
transactions per month big B that's a
big B over a billion per day on
WebSphere right so the scale and
performance is there that you need now
when you're ready to move into to dot o
that Steve talked about DevOps micro
services containers etc part of the
WebSphere family includes Liberty we
release WebSphere Liberty back in 2012
containerized WebSphere right in 2012
and we've made a lot of enhancements
since that time WebSphere Liberty is
that kernel of out of your application
platform so you can start small and then
grow as big as you need to without
changing your application architecture
at all part of succeeding with Webster
with with micro services and containers
is actually engaging a robust developer
community we have two and a half million
developers who build applications for
WebSphere containerized Liberty on the
docker hub WebSphere Liberty has been
downloaded three point
eight million times so you're in good
hands you've got a strong and vibrant
community behind you using WebSphere and
last year we took Liberty and released
open Liberty to the open source
community six and a half million lines
of code IBM's largest open source
contribution ever now when you're ready
for cloud 3.0 game-changing you want to
be the disrupter in your industry right
you want to be ahead of the pack and
delight your clients WebSphere has api's
for Watson and blockchain we released
microclimate and into n DevOps toolchain
not only for Java but also for node and
Swift applications that toolchain will
take your developers every where they
need to be to create new applications
build them deploy them test them manage
them throughout the application
lifecycle so an incredible amount of
capabilities in the WebSphere portfolio
and it's working
[Music]
[Applause]